this next section we're going to be
focusing on Modern soft strategy really
we're going to build off the framework
that Desi Logan presented during our
Keynote additionally we're going to have
Peter Bergen who's a senior CNN news
analyst to moderate the presentation for
four panelists we're going to have about
50 minutes for them to engage in
conversation
additionally we'll have about 15-20
minutes of q a again please think about
some questions we want this to be
interactive we want some
provocative thoughts some ideas to flow
so think about that as Peter moderates
this conversation thank you thank you
Mike
um also we have an All-Star panel
directly to my left is Colonel Jewell
who's the director of the Adaptive
Innovative statecraft unit at Json
multiple combat tours in Iraq
Mexico is Colonel hooker who amongst
other things was senior director for
Europe and Russia at the NSC between
2017 and 2018 kind of an interesting
time to be doing that
um and also was the Teddy Roosevelt
chair at ndu he's now a senior fellow at
the Atlantic Council
next to him is Ben Milligan who is uh I
was on Seal Team four and five he just
wrote this book by water beneath the
walls the rise of the Navy Seals I read
150 pages of it last night I could not
put it down it is so good uh took him
seven years to write
um and next to him is Colonel Collins
who is the executive director of the
viola Foundation the editor of The
Rutledge uh handbook on U.S Canada U.S
counterterrorism in the regular Warfare
which is a absolutely massive and
authoritative book which was done in the
memory of Mike Sheehan who was ASD
soleic and probably some of you now
remember Mike he is also the author
co-author of understanding Urban Warfare
which I think is going to be a useful
discussion Point here
and he used to direct the
counterterrorism center at West Point so
I'm just going to start with um Colonel
tunnel hooker if you don't mind
because you wrote what I thought was a
rather provocative piece
in the um
which you can describe perhaps and give
us the it's a I would say a blistering
critique of Special Operations as they
are presently constructed so go ahead
well okay
thanks for that I guess still kind of
wondering why I was invited to this
conference
I want to lead up by saying uh what I
said in my jfq article up front which is
that undeniably special operating forces
have a key role to play in National
Security
undeniably special operating forces have
a key role to play in National Security
I want to put that up front
but I hope to inject you know some
balance into the conversation today and
I hope I don't trigger anybody in the
room but but maybe that wouldn't be such
a bad thing after all I'm going to give
you a perspective from outside the soft
Community from the conventional
Community but also I think from the
policy making uh
point of view which is informed by I
guess my three tours on the National
Security Council
so uh
let's talk a little bit about some of
the trends in the soft Community really
really since 9 11. so the first is a
real explosion in size so so soft
doubled in size from 911 to the present
present day how did it do that the
fourth Battalion was added to hsf group
along with a Special Troops Battalion
Military Intelligence Battalion added to
the 75th Ranger regiment which also
added the fourth rifle company
and his support company in each
Battalion and on and on and on
um I've got a document here that's put
out by the assistant secretary of
defense for Manpower and Reserve affairs
which I found really interesting in
doing the research for the article so I
was kind of dumbfounded to read that
where the joint staff has 2 390 folks
assigned
and centcom has
1466 this was in 2020.
U.S silicon had 6194.
well now when you push this forward to
the most current document which is an
estimate of f522
the numbers are about the same for the
joint staff for the other combatant
commands Socom comes in at 73 923
which I think is the entire community
so so why that methodology is applied to
this number and to no one else I'm not
sure but but there is an answer out
there somewhere it might be to obscure
the side of the so-called staff
it's not clear to me why the socom staff
needs to be exponentially larger than
everybody else but but maybe somebody in
the room can help me out with that
so a big explosion in size
so the obvious kind of question to that
is how do you maintain the quality of
the force when you've doubled in size
so we'll we'll get into that a little
bit later in my presentation I think
that as he told us that soft forces uh
when compared to everyone else are
not putting words in your mouth dirt
cheap two percent or whatever whatever
well they're pretty expensive actually
because a lot of the costs are hidden in
service budgets so Manpower costs for
example is one but many acquisition
costs as well
even so socom's budget requests for the
current year was larger than the entire
defense budget of Poland
which is NATO's largest and strongest
military
at least until Ukraine gets in which
hopefully won't be too much longer
um so that's an interesting statistic
so comes inventory of 30 AC 130j
aircraft comes in 165 million dollars
each so that's more than enough 22
that's more than an F-35 and this is an
aircraft that can only find permissive
environments is typically only used at
night and is almost never used in
support of conventional units even in
extremis
another example might be the
at8802u light aircraft which is a
modified crop duster that socoma tends
to use for close air support and armed
OverWatch
and this program will come in at three
billion dollars so
I mean is that is that a example of an
acquisition that's going to make a lot
of sense in great power competition and
high intensity major theater War not so
sure about that
I would say paradoxically although
expected to conduct operations with the
highest levels of discipline and
discretion in fact a disproportionate
number of the most egregious mishaps in
the war on terror Bethel soft units and
I'm not going to give you a long laundry
list although I have one if you're
interested but if you picked a military
disaster from 2001 up to about 2018 or
so there's about an 80 percent chance
that it involved the soft unit not a
conventional unit
and I I think that calls for some
inquiry into why that might be in fact
there was an inquiry that was
commissioned by General Clark in 2019
after some Congressional pressure
which resulted in some findings which I
thought were interesting but not sure if
it got to the bottom of that uh it it
may well be and you all might know
better than me and may have something to
do with optempo
we could have a conversation about that
it may have something to do with the
explosion and size of the force it may
have something to do with the
connectivity or lack of connectivity
with battle space owners there's a lot
to unpack there
but I think this is significant
um
I think a major contributing factor to
what we're talking about here is the
strong tendency to wall off or to
stovepipe
Spencer operations forces so I'm going
to
I'm going to throw a thesis out on the
table here which I believe is sort of an
iron law of bureaucratic politics which
is that all organizations Boy Scouts of
America First Presbyterian Church of
Dothan or U.S Socom they all want two
things
they want the maximum amount of autonomy
and then what the maximum amount of
resources that they could get
now some organizations prosper and are
super effective at this Marine Corps is
an example that comes to mind and some
are less successful
I would venture to to say that the U.S
so calm is spectacularly successful at
this
so put yourself in the shoes of General
Petraeus in 2007 at mnfi
and the poor guy has got direct control
over army forces
but the Marines are not task organized
under him the Air Force is not task
organized under him as a theater
Commander blacksoft is not task
organized under him and white soft is
Task organized at the four-star level
which means for tactical actions that
are going on every single day there
there is no relationship there you can't
monitor or manage those at the four-star
level you just can't
so if you're a battle space owner I'm
sorry you're going to have a lot of soft
units running around in your battle
space and I and I can tell you this from
personal experience as a unit Commander
and five different campaigns and you're
not going to know that they're there
and maybe it's okay and maybe it's not
going to be okay so that's a problem
so if we believe that Unity of effort is
important then I submit we need to
strive for True Unity of effort which
means let's get a line synchronized
integrated and coordinated on the
battlefield
let's not set up a huge wall
so that we could be as autonomous as we
want to be
and I know I'm being provocative here
but I think this is a conversation that
needs to take place a tournament master
has written at some length
about the rating strategy that was that
was uh carried out by by Soft forces all
through the campaigns in Iraq and
Afghanistan which in a real way tended
to work against the rest of the theater
strategy so what we're trying to do is
protect the civilian population and win
the civilian population over to our side
which is a tentative counter-insurgency
then constantly traumatizing the
civilian population with night raids
some of which were successful but many
of which were not tended to work at
counter purposes to the theater strategy
it really did
and I think this is something that we
need to learn from and think about as we
project the role of of soft into the
next era
which is going to certainly uh feature
some elements of uh going after violent
extremist organizations but is probably
going to have a higher priority of
trying to posture to be effective and to
contribute to our success in high
intensity major theater War
so I think these are some of the things
that that we need to think about as we
look into the near term and to the
midterm I'd mention one other point in
passing which I do think is important
and which I would call your attention to
which is
and we have an explosion of the soft the
way that we had in the last 20 years or
so it can only come at the expense of
the leadership Cadre of our conventional
units so by skimming the cream off the
conventional units there is a cost and
it's a I submit to you pretty high cost
Army Special Forces or the Army soft
Community probably accounts for
something on the order of 5 000
non-commissioned officers many of whom
are at that critical E6 and E7 level
that are deposited now in the soft
community and can't be leading soldiers
in the conventional Force that's a
really big number that's enough ncos
really to Cadre about an Army Corps
so I guess the relevant question here is
is the return on that investment better
by by putting them in the shop Community
or with the return on that investment be
better by leaving them leading soldiers
in the conventional Community I think
that's an interesting question a quick
vignette my son was a platoon leader in
the 82nd Airborne Division the day that
qasim solomoni was killed his baton was
on drf1 so no notice they they blew out
to Iraq to secure the embassy
uh with none of its E6 Squad leaders
authorized they had all departed for the
Q course and he was the fourth platoon
leader in that platoon in one calendar
year
this previous three lieutenants had all
departed for Special Forces or their
Ranger regiment and this is in the 82nd
Airborne Division which in theory is
supposed to be maintained at the highest
level of Manning and Readiness that we
have
so it's it's a it's a tough problem to
deal with as a battalion commander in
the 82nd I I lost 16 ncos in one
calendar year to to the Q course
that's a crippling blow
and you don't really have a vote as a
commander about when these folks leave
when it's time for them to go to the
selection they go to selection and you
don't really get a vote in all of that
so
um I'll leave it to others to say if
that is a a price worth paying I just
want flag for you that there is a cost
or a price to be paid in terms of
pulling a lot of quality leaders out of
the conventional Force as we re-posture
for great power competition and we move
away from sort of the coin G1
environment I'll close for that but look
forward to your questions I hope
there'll be some thanks very much
my guess is there might be Colonel
Jewell since you're one of the uh
employees of Socom as part of gsouth
over to you
thank you
thank you Richard you're very welcome
a lot in that and uh I'll address a
little bit of it after I give you a
little pitch from our perspective at the
Joint Special Operations University and
uh the center that I am the director of
uh has a long name and Peter got it
right but we basically run the long-term
research projects for the University
this goes to something secretary Logan
said and something you said richer about
learning
uh and how to adapt to what we did so
our long-term history projects are
social science research
history and Theory informed
applied to current problems
in the command in the in the Enterprise
uh specifically we're aligned now with
paycom or sorry sock pack sakur sock AF
and socks South on four of our key
products one is serving directly to our
commander and his command teams as
they're looking at how to transform
Socom
people win transform as a mantra in the
headquarters how to transform Special
Operations Command into soft Enterprise
to contribute soft peculiar capabilities
to integrated deterrents
in compound security competition
to deter left of for example China Aziz
China invading Taiwan for example
something changing in Europe with our
acute threat even more troubling than it
has occurred and how do we build the
force and yes build is what we're
talking about Richard so that's a little
opposite of of what your your
suggestions are there to be able to
contribute to soft peculiar things to
deterrent integrated deterrence with
joint interagency in a governmental
multinational and Commercial partners
and these research projects are the
engine of what President Wilson the Json
president calls Socom think do tank
because we don't do that just to serve
those commands we're working with we do
that to cycle education and create
knowledge back into the education of the
soft of the combined joint soft
Professionals for life
that's a sales pitch I'm still
practicing it I've been in the job since
January 1st
but during that time we sat in on the
Silicon Commander's Commander's decision
roundtables looking at a journey as he
describes it to transform soft transform
both the way we employ the forces
pushing that more down to the tsox and
the commands
and how we
manage the force as a service like
organization
that's a pretty big step after
the G watt years
one of the theories that Jason proposes
is a history and Theory based background
to look at this practice What's called
the four ages of soft
I think bins binge book doesn't use
those terms but he landed on very
similar things in it so in the modern
era of soft not counting Special
Operations on conventional Warfare
regular Warfare that occurred long
before our civil war that occurred long
before our Revolution that are worth
studying in places as that history and
Theory
but we start about the time of World War
II when we started bringing together
soft as formations to apply in that
context support conventional operations
we weren't really doing a lot before uh
a lot we were doing some with our
partners or British partners then in the
60s in the Vietnam era we grew the force
to go along with more or less
conventional operations relatively low
intensity which is a term I don't love
but still you know the war in Vietnam
and then after operation Eagle Claw
was a huge threshold moment that we
didn't first see one of those tragedies
one of those great tragedies our
conference room in Jay foul is named
after Eagle Claw the changes that came
from law from Congress not from the
command
that said in motion the creation of
Special Operations Command that set in
motion the creation of the assistant
Secretary directorate of solic
to go forward in soft peculiar things it
also included education
uh Mr Locker who's one of the champions
of that who we we talk with every now
and then has said that they didn't get
the education part right they did say we
have a university
but we didn't get to all the things we
think we need to educate soft
Professionals for life
in some people Dave's mind I think we
are leaning towards being more
service-like that's Dave's opinion how
much more
secretary a lot of people have to have
have clearer Visions on it but that goes
kind of counter to what what Richard was
saying here I grew up in the
conventional Army almost entirely in the
intelligence community and I watched
much a lot of great talent move over
into Special Operations community
I just took that as a challenge to
develop the talent we have
and keep them and listening to what
their core tasks are where they're
different from soft peculiar
so now we have another threshold moment
again Eagle Claw 911 was an another one
that caused us to go predominantly
towards the CT functions and towards
crisis response which remains our no
fail function in soft
at the expense of some of the other the
12 functions we did
and now at this threshold after the end
of the giwa wars we think to support
integrated deterrence to support
integrated returns and competition
the the the pasture remains fertile to
grow in the areas of civil affairs for
internal defense
countering weapons of mass destruction
which softest actually got the
responsibility for as recently as 2016
even though it had been one of our core
activities going back to the beginning
and at Jason we're trying to set the
education for soft professionals so that
we can learn from the bad examples and
the good examples apply Theory to it
social social science theory
international relations Theory
apply technology technology to enable
the way we learn in the conversation
earlier about machine learning and
artificial intelligence I was interested
and I got some things to say but that's
not my expertise
but one thing we're doing with some of
that
in in Jason is trying to empower our
education with geospatial tools
informed by current social media current
news and classical Theory
geospatially accessible at the
unclassified level for our professor for
our students for units much like the old
CIA handbooks you know when I first went
to a foreign country in the early 90s
make one of those that's enriched with
current geospatial data that's part of
one of our research but it's alongside
our research projects
because that information is very
difficult to find in a unified space
certainly on the unclassified level
which is where we're we're working
and there is one thing I wanted to get
to uh to kind of respond to which it's
not a debate
um
but again I'm an army Intel guy and I'm
used to the three telling me I'm wrong
about the enemy and I'll say I've
studied it for a while
uh
one I don't know the answer to why we
somebody reported the whole soft
formation as a as the same as the
headquarters I don't know
um that's not correct the other number
was about correct
and the money it was the assistant
Secretary of Defense who reported it so
okay and I'm not just somebody
out of my realm and I don't doubt the
report
we don't have 73 000 people in Tampa
I'm sure you don't we do not you know
they could they wouldn't even all fit in
the football stadium or the bus
um
in the money again Mr innocent and atnl
and the technology was outside of me but
the soft peculiar of some of the weapon
systems you named
is a different addition to the force
it's a different addition to deterrence
integrated returns to influence I think
I've asked myself in the times why don't
we have
uh the RMC 130 is in the conventional
Force I don't know but they do provide
something in a way of low visibility
something in a way of of of unique
capacity that is soft peculiar
and if so calm and specifically if Jay
Sao is educating on something that is
not mostly soft peculiar then we're
stepping on the grounds of the services
um or other folks and so we try to find
what's soft peculiar
which combined doing soft peculiar in a
GMC joint interagency International or
intergovernmental
darn it I forget it
what's the multinational and Commercial
environment and those are Partnerships
that Jason as part of Socom has
Where We Are
as an organization unencumbered by the
classified work that Socom does
President Wilson went to Taiwan in
December to have a discussion with the
Taiwan National Defense University
that's not the exact name of it
education based
which hadn't been done at that level
that included
tens of two and three star
Republic of China
military and Department of Foreign
Affairs leaders talking about what they
educationally think they need to be
concerned about the security of Taiwan
small contribution
building a relationship that is not to
replace what the military formations are
doing but then we come back and talk
about that and in fact indo-paycomp had
people there and so did uh sock pack
so that's part of what we're trying to
do to work between so I'm an employee at
Socom
I'm the guy that my president looks at
most of the time to work with what our
headquarters does because before I came
to this job I was in our headquarters
being a typical normal military planner
guy
and try to translate that back into
research
for the education of soft Professionals
for life I think I've gone too long and
I will stop thank you thank you I'm
going to turn the colonel Collins is
also a retired Special Forces officer I
just want to inject also just into the
conversation of as we move forward
one of the premises of this discussion I
think may be
um we should I'm trying to unpack a bit
which is the G Ward is over and you know
it's all about great peer competition
and I'm reminded and you can tell me if
I'm wrong Colonel Collins but you know
at West Point the generation the crystal
Petraeus odiano generation you know the
Vietnam War was almost like a verbot in
the subject and it was put in the rear
view rear view mirror and are we making
some version of the same mistake now
with because obviously the National
Security defense well you know the Trump
National Security defense strategy the
the Biden they're very similar they
emphasize the same things but are we
um going to make another version of the
same mistake which is by putting this
thing in the rear view mirror basically
be unprepared for the next time
something like this comes up
yeah I mean I think there's less a
mistake of that happening this time but
I mean you know the dod we love to swing
that pendulum and if you want to justify
a 700 billion dollar budget you have to
have a huge enemy to justify that budget
so we want to right you've got to have a
an enemy out there to justify a massive
budget uh so you have that and so yeah
talking about the swing to great power
competition so uh you know I think a few
years ago so calm at times has kind of
had this identity crisis of what's our
role going to be in this are we going to
lose our budget share as we kind of
switch to great power competition which
is kind of unfathomable to me because
you just have to look at our history or
look at how they're employed and and
that's not a fear but I think there's a
few reasons why this fear is probably uh
why they had it I mean one is I've
argued with Mike Sheehan and Mark
Mitchell about why the office is called
ASD sole that get rid of low intensity
conflict from the title names and titles
matter means the rest of the services
anything to deal with low intensity
conflict they just push off to soft
because that's where it belongs it
belongs in this office that's not ours
when they have a role in it and then
soft is then also left wondering if what
were if we belong to Special Operations
low intensity conflict what's our role
in great power competition because that
maybe isn't our realm when it's always
been the realm so just fix the title the
office and you'll pick some of these
problems and the third thing is we all
know it's not low intensity if you're
the one getting shot at that's pretty
freaking High intense when that's going
on uh but I mean titles matter and I
think that's one thing uh but in terms
of the great power competition I've
always hated this name too it's great
power conflict don't
if you think we're not at conflict with
Russia and China you're wrong ask them
ask Chinese and ask the Russians we are
at conflict right the problem is we have
this very narrow binary definition of
war and not war and that's not how they
view the world and when we view it from
that perspective we're always going to
be a disadvantage for for this great
power competition so I hate that word uh
but again it's unfathomable to me like
soft would sometimes question what our
role is in this
when we've always had a role we're going
to be employed right as Aaron said
earlier right a massive role in this but
I think part of the problem is right
then coming out of the G wat in 20 years
of this so that's 20 years so your
entire generation of officers that's all
they know right and and during this
there was I will agree with some of the
points Richard made now disagree with
others but part of it was there was way
too much soft doing direct action during
the conflict right maybe the seals
should be doing it Rangers should be
doing it select elements of soft doing
it but too many times Special Forces
elements were doing direct action when
they should be building a host nation
force and that was not helpful I
remember in ramadi in 2004 talking to an
ODB Commander so an SF company Commander
that had six detachments in Iraq and he
was being directed to do foreign
internal defense and he said I don't
want to do that we want to go do targets
I'm like as opposed to developing a 350
man or Battalion and then you'd have all
these Intel assets for for them to hit
targets they could hit so many more than
you could hit but part of the problem is
right that that's what soft attracts
right soft attracts a bunch of people
that want to do direct action and that
is not the primary role of stuff very
for a small number of soft forces that's
it you're talking National Mission force
rangers and the Army that's the main
thing right not special forces but
that's who they that's who they attract
and then you wonder why you have this
dissonance between what they want to do
and what they're going to do uh you know
to hit up on on some of the things
Richard talked about uh I'm not sure
what what I don't doubt that was the
case in his environment about the you
know black soft or white soft running
around and not being coordinated I can
just tell you everywhere I operated that
was never a problem before I did any
raid I talked to the the owning force on
the ground about it after we got done I
talked to him
uh and that was whether it was with
General ordierno on down to lower level
or General Mattis I I remember a time
where right when we were building all
our general crystals build and all the
liaison networks expanding them
everywhere and he came to visit General
Mattis and he said I don't I don't need
a liaison officer I got Liam here
but he was right he needed liaison
officer because I'm I'm working
full-time I can't spend all my time at
the division
um but I disagree with that we had Unity
of effort everywhere I was at even if we
didn't have unity of command they're
going to be different and that's the
problem that's that's got to be
addressed but I don't think that's the
solution uh and and the owning forces it
was never a problem I remember another
fourth infantry division they had
a brigade uh operations officer called
me up one time and said hey do you know
anything about this target it was white
white seal so we're hitting the Target
and I said nope just tell them that did
they tell you why they're hitting it or
who it is and they said no I said tell
them they can't hit it you own the
terrain they can't hit it if you tell
them not to hit it I'm like I tell you
every single Target I'm gonna hit
because for all I know you have a
relationship with him I don't even need
to hit the target because you can go out
and get him for me uh and so I disagree
with that to some extent
uh right the the talent problem of the
talent drain that you were talking about
Richard I mean I think that's not a
problem of soft stealing people I think
it's a problem with the conventional
Army that people wouldn't be leaving it
more than likely in terms of why are
they going to soft because it's not
being handled right they aren't seeing
satisfaction in conventional Army and
the rager regiment actually is a benefit
to right the army they don't go there
and stay there they go out there to
Ranger regiment and they come right back
after doing time there uh and take those
skills so I would disagree about those
forces stealing Talent from from the
from the service uh I think it's a the
problem is probably more with the
service level uh than anything else
um in terms of
uh yeah I mean Budget yeah I would agree
right there we have an insational uh I
mean amazing ability to grow and spend
money I'm a little concerned not with
soft growth because there's plenty of
missions there right we'll never have
the missions that we you know we'll
always have more missions we can ever
execute again that why should we ever
have an identity crisis never right we
will always be there's more things we
can do than we will ever do and things
that we should be doing but we're we're
always going to be short of people my my
greatest fear with the growth is we were
never at 100 before we added fourth
battalions we were never at 100 before
we added squadrons how the heck can you
add grow when you've never had that you
just have so many talented operators or
analysts or whatever it is to put in
these places that's the bigger problem
to me uh right the people are the most
important thing and I always joke it
wasn't a joke but right if you haven't
what's supposed to be a 12 person
Detachment you go from nine to ten but
that 10th person is a negative really
you've grown from nine to eight because
you've got to have somebody watch this
person that's a uh right can cause Mass
to strategic harm to your to your nation
right by these people out there as I
think Richard kind of pointed out some
of those things uh you know the last
thing I'll do I'll I'll say in in terms
of we we shouldn't insert it I'll talk
about uh the Forgotten soft forces here
briefly civil Affairs and psyops that we
never we never talk about uh but they're
part of it too
um we should not send forces somewhere
without actually having a a way to
actually measure their performance and
you can do it right too often we measure
right measures of performance not
measures of Effectiveness and we and
there's ways to do this right survey
data other ways to do it but uh was
doing a project for uh for one of the
Civil Affairs groups and because they
had they had multiple elements out there
in Europe all doing kind of similar
things for different purposes all over
Europe and I said well how do you know
if you're effective he's like I have no
idea that's why I'm coming to you and
have the cadets look at this project are
we actually being effective uh and so
figuring that out like right it's there
they're a small asset let's figure out
where we can deploy this assets we get
the most return on the investment uh and
so you got to think about how do you
actually measure that going in and if we
can't measure it sometimes you I mean
there's ways to get at it right uh but
we should that should be part of the
process when you're thinking about
deploying an asset how do we measure its
actual effectiveness
what do we what do we mean by
Effectiveness so that's kind of it but
bottom line I mean soft has a major role
to play in great power competition right
building host nation capability right
access and placement uh building these
relations that we can leverage I mean
one of the best examples and a success
story during the last 20 years is oefpi
the Philippines right very small print
why did it work there because no one in
the in the in the U.S military cared
about it because we were all in
Afghanistan and Iraq so you had a very
small Force being very effective there
and more often than not right soft is
most effective when we're actually
forced to stay small like we did in El
Salvador we did in Colombia again
Columbia wasn't effective encounter drug
but effective from counter Insurgency uh
right Philippines right these are places
and and so one of the lessons is hey we
have to be artificially restricted to be
in small or we will grow too big and you
actually grow to be ineffective
thanks Peter thank you oh what I forgot
to mention right he didn't mention that
I'm also a a fellow with new America
which Peter is the uh president new
America so vice president uh who cares
uh so Ben you did I have a terrible pun
here you did the deepest of deep Dives
on the history of the U.S Navy Seals
um what are what are the lessons and one
I don't know how many 150 pages and I
thought it was absolutely brilliant and
I what I one of the lessons I took away
was how many times certain units were
kind of created in for specific
situations and then sort of disbanded
over time uh as the the rationale for
their existence seemed to fade or
because of bureaucratic infighting as
you look forward to uh you know the
pivot obviously is from the geot to to
great power competition even if you
don't necessarily agree that that
actually is the main um yeah that's
where the defense establishment is so
what based on your sort of own
historical understanding of this
how do you see it this playing out for
the units that grew up so spectacularly
in the in the war against terrorism
I don't know
um great answer
right right just make it up uh thank you
Peter thanks for the question thanks uh
for my co-panelists and thanks for the
invitation Mike to be here this is my
first panel so uh this is a treat
um
you to to catch everybody up uh to speed
on what Peter is talking about uh the
early history of soft is is in fact very
choppy uh uh it's um there's periods of
stagnation explosion
um uh merging of units together uh one
of the thing that Peter mentioned was uh
particularly the the early creations and
disbandments of various units that that
happens uh uh uh
lots of times so probably the best
examples of that are the Marine Corps
Raiders that are created in 1942 they
have some sort of spectacular operations
uh they're publicized in a very popular
movie at the time and a few weeks after
the movie comes out they're disbanded
similar thing happens with the Army
Rangers Army Rangers are created in
1942. half of the Rangers are committed
to a disastrous raid in Italy
they're disbanded uh the three other
Ranger battalions continue on in World
War II 1945 no more Rangers Korean War
comes along Army needs a sort of a
rating capability again they
re-establish the Rangers eight months
after that Ranger Rangers are disbanded
again they're not re-established uh as a
uh as a real Force there's there's sort
of Ranger type units that have that are
brought back in in Vietnam but the
Rangers as we know them are not really
recreated until 1974. so there is this
period of of sort of creation disband
merging together uh and so I think the
question that we're all sort of trying
to understand in this room
is how do we how do we move forward into
the uh this new environment where we
have these new threats
um great power conflict is Liam Liam
said well I think it's interesting to
know
um at least for that first 20 30-year
period of soft uh we were always in
great power conflict I mean we've been
in a new generation now uh where we
we've had this uh maybe
incorrect uh perception that we haven't
been in great power competition because
our conflict because we've been focusing
on uh Insurgency groups low intensity
conflict stuff but if we want to
understand why we are in the current
situation and how to project forward
from that how we have 130 c-130s why we
have a a colonel hooker said a potential
Talent drain from the regular service
branches why we have
um why the ASD solo position is has that
low and density conflict uh acronym at
the end of it I think we have to
understand how we got here and one trick
that you learn is if you are a historian
if you're if you're going to write
history is in order to understand why
questions the first thing that you need
to do is understand what happened put
things in order why we'll always come to
the surface if you just start to put
things in order
um
and I think uh most of us have this idea
that special operation history is this
is the story of tension uh tension
between uh conventional leaders and
unconventional leaders
um
and that's true uh at absolutely
absolutely is true
um there have been biases in the
military against Elite troops from the
very beginning of our history most
notably though we start to see them in
World War II you have leaders like Mark
Clark
even leaders like uh like Eisenhower and
George Marshall that are very very
reluctant to create Elite uh troops
within the ranks
of one because they don't want other
troops to feel like their uh their
services less
important than the elite troops but also
for practical reasons they don't want
the best troops in their organizations
uh to to flee and join those other uh
better organ or you know
um more famous or more whatever you want
to call it those other units so there's
practicalities and those are absolutely
all true those those all happen and
they're part of the story and how we got
here and the part of that tension but
it's also Worth US remembering that all
of the unconventional units that we have
today were all started by conventional
leaders we have
leaders throughout our history that
never served a day in anything you would
even consider remotely special or
unconventional Admiral King Kelly Turner
John McGee Bill Darby all these guys
they were all they all came from
conventional units
so I think it's important to really
understand
how the real story happened I I we we
got here or the the tension that existed
uh is I think really uh was a result of
partly great power competition
um it was difficult in those early years
of Special Operations to sort of uh
figure out where there was a place for
these sort of behind the lines Raiders
uh or behind the lines whatever I always
uh when I I was doing research for the
book I sort of created a little Matrix
for myself to understand what a special
operations unit was and I started to you
know with all the acronyms of things at
Special Operations forces do I boiled it
down into the I call the three R's of
Special Operations Recon wrecking and
raiding
but in order to understand you know what
a special operation was I started to
like think about like well what you know
what defines a special operation because
you could have an elite unit or a
special unit that can be doing a
conventional operation or vice versa you
can have a conventional unit that's
doing a special operation so what is a
special operation so I started to think
okay well if you it's usually Behind
Enemy Lines if it's not Behind Enemy
Lines it's at least beyond the forward
line of Trope so if you're going to have
a unit that's going to be operating in
the forward line of troops or Behind
Enemy Lines it's going to have it's
going to be
um
uh it's going to have to move at night
at some point it's going to have to get
to its Target or wherever it's going to
have to be done at night in order for
that unit to move at night it's going to
have to be small for a unit to move at
night effectively and quietly it's got
to be small and because it's small it
has to sort of it has to be targeting a
a Target that's vulnerable so that
little triangle helped me kind of
understand so those three things if they
got out of whack and it ceased to sort
of be a special operation
anyway so how do we get uh how do we get
this institution that we have now and I
think that's the biggest story of uh uh
of of American Special Operations so we
have this whole period uh where all of
these sort of Patchwork units are
operating independently but now we have
this uh as as Colonel hooker was
describing it we've got this massive
industry of Special Operations that is
uh protected from the top it's supported
from the bottom
um it's uh it's like it's how America
does you know everything we we you know
take something small and we build it up
into a major corporation and the fear
now being
um well Are we more bureaucratic
probably
um are we less able to respond to
current threats possibly yeah but
there's a reason that we have that
bureaucracy because there were all these
other things that sort of forced us to
create that bureaucracy so if we look at
what happened in history I think we can
get there
um
anyway I could keep going but I'll I'll
stop for now let me honest counterclones
because you just came back from Ukraine
I mean obviously one of the big
successes in the Ukrainian war is
Ukrainian soft and Major General re-pass
has been part of that who some people
here may know I mean and now of course
the training is sort of being done over
Face Time essentially I mean right it's
it's not in theater so why was that a
success
um and and you know what is the likely
outcome going forward given the fact
that it's not Hands-On in the same way
yeah first I'll answer I mean I'll say
it was a failure to deter and we I think
we could have done it
um but there was no will in the U.S
government to actually do it um so it's
been a little bit of time on that if
that's okay
um partly because right that there was
no punishment for Russia in 2008
following their invasion of Georgia
nothing in 2014 2015 following their
their initial invasion in illegal
annexation into Ukraine uh we did have a
300 million dollar you know roughly year
investment that we were doing over there
and I spent two years going back and
forth with General abbazade so I I
understand kind of saw the ukrainians
evolve from 2016 to 2018.
um we asked you know one of the things
we did and this was you know one of the
many signals is we asked both the shape
Commander we asked General Mattis to put
a general officer in charge of the
ground of the effort in Ukraine we had a
two to three hundred man joint military
training group you train over there
training them
you know half a dozen Ministry defense
advisors over there uh all these other
kind of in and out things and 350 you
know million dollar Aid package and you
look at other places we've had this kind
of thing uh Pakistan when we needed when
we needed to go into Pakistan right
needed help from them we put Mike nagada
there uh when we you know Israel like
Saudi Arabia some other places right
when you need it that's that's a signal
right that's the thing that the Russia
you care about it uh but the answer was
we don't have a general to give or
Admiral to give despite having 620 in
the Department of Defense it meant we
didn't care and we were communicating to
Russia we cared so what bottom line it
was a failure to deter and we are where
we're at today uh but yeah ukrainians I
mean one of the one of the things uh
everybody that we talked to over there
over a two year period every single
person said they're not Iraqi or
afghanis right if you look at what what
can the U.S do what does the U.S not do
well we don't build a military on scale
in a nation where there's no political
will to do it and no one's good at that
right that's why it failed in
Afghanistan and Iraq and that's why it
worked in Ukraine the political was
behind it they're the ones that wanted
to reform and turn turn Western you'll
probably if you go to the panel later
today you'll have somebody very critical
of it
um but you know I'll cut it shorter on
there but bottom line is the soft did a
very good job training there is they
basically stood it up from scratch over
there uh and
um because they're kind of better at
building it than some of the other
conventional assets so you know uh have
built it pretty effective and so yeah
what's what's really dependent on uh on
Ukraine has continued Western Aid to
support support the ukrainians uh
because you basically got a military
that's got the advantage in every
category except for mass mass is the one
category Russia has the advantage uh and
so they got to kind of continue to
replace those weapon systems but yeah
they did a good job of building it
because I think on Iraq I mean I would
respectfully disagree I think with the
Iraqi counterterrorism service it's one
it's one of the sort of great unheralded
successes Niche Force very good at
building a niche for us okay we can't
build a force on scale coach
okay any questions
Eric Donahue I'm gonna I'm an assault
team leader at uh Development Group I
have a question uh
Dr Collins based on what you just said
about the uh efforts in Ukraine could
you give some examples of what is the
Ukrainian special forces are doing that
makes those operations
defined as special kind of according to
the three tenets that Mr Milligan spoke
about a lot of the stuff you know we see
in the news and open source media seems
like it's mainly conventional warfare
that's taking place during the daytime
would you be able to give some examples
yeah I mean it just I mean just think of
the defensive key for example it's
really hard to understand the Ukrainian
Army coming in with a western
perspective or a U.S perspective of how
Wars are fought like it's kind of like
our inherent distrust with our
government they kind of have that
inherent the Ukrainian population has
this inherent distrust with their
military
so going back to 2014 right a massive
number of volunteers went out to the to
the east to really defend against the
russian-led separatists
so they have this really weird construct
where you have this you know standing
regular army but then you have just you
still have these massive volunteers from
the defensive key if you would have
civilians basically running the drones
establishing all the named area of
Interest like
looking out there talking right there
with commanders so where was this some
of the the their special forces role in
this
most of their Force Rarities they really
thought the attack was going to come
here so they're really left with a 72nd
mechanized Brigade kind of Defending
capital and they're really kind of just
at the the edge of the city limits as
far as they went pretty much everything
forward of that was just civilians
carrying weapons and kind of
step out there kind of working with them
I mean as an example right and so
they're they're working with those guys
or they might have the you know RPG or
an in-law and then they're kind of
working working with the Ambush as a
approach to the conventional forces so
just kind of strange in that way
um I don't think they've had as much
success really to kind of build in that
resistance Network and I think there's a
couple reasons why I don't want to get
too much in Ukraine because we're going
to hit it later you know we got a
separate panel for it but I think it's
uh because right one is a lot of
ukrainians are just leaving right when
when the war comes to you you get the
hell out of there right I mean most
people leave cities and once you're left
so I think you haven't seen as much
resistance as you could and part of it
was that those resistance Network to be
most effective had to be set up in
advance and they weren't set up in
advance I mean even I did a video
teleconference with kind of the the
forces responsible for defendant Kiev
and this Commander is is basically you
know three weeks before the war started
he you know no one believed that the
Russians were going to invade so they
really weren't prepared for it from that
perspective uh and then I think they're
they're doing some deep raids too
but yeah I mean but it it's it's a weird
construct the way they're you would
never have a civilian come to the bunker
on the second day of the war and come up
with a plan to blow a dam and then just
say go here we'll give an engineer go to
the ammo supply Point pick up to pick up
a ton of TNT or dynamite and blow the
dam but just unheard of
in the absence of other questions do you
have a question
yeah
hi uh will Myers I'm an assault team
leader over at uh Gable Stone uh for
Colonel hooker and uh Dr Collins you
kind of got on this as well how do you
resolve the conflict in in your mind if
Special Operations is a drain on the
talent of uh the conventional Force how
to resolve the issue of the fact that
you know it's not like if you're a
conventional guy
it's not like you're going to stay in
the conventional Army if you don't go to
soft maybe you just get out of the army
you know you know as we talk about it
being a drain maybe it's just an
opportunity you know someone someone
like myself I wouldn't I've been in the
Army 16 years I wouldn't have been in
the Army 16 years if I had to stay
conventional uh kroger how do you how do
you address that
well if you break that down I think what
you're really saying is all these guys
that migrate to to the soft Community
are either going to migrate to the soft
Community or they're going to get out
there's just no social science behind
that there's no data behind that that's
all anecdotal stuff the E6 is the go to
selection and don't make selection
typically don't all get out of the army
because they've got 10 years eight years
11 years invested
they're looking at retirement down the
road so the community is very large
there's going to be a suction pump
effect that's going to draw
talented or quality leaders you know
into that side of the force the the
question that we need to be asking is
sort of the the policy and the strategy
level is is that where these folks make
the biggest contribution
at the end of the day you don't win Wars
with Commandos you just don't
we'll win them probably with heavy
divisions and we're their power
now there's a as I said it in my very
opening remarks there's a key role for
soft to play in the Nash security
toolbox no doubt about that
but my critique is that we've become
unbalanced that's all I'm just trying to
you know promote this idea that we need
to sort of rebalance
um let's get back into the joint game
let's put all the tools Under The Joint
Force Commander and stop taking tools
away from The Joint Force Commander so
that we can integrate and coordinate and
synchronize and get better effects on
the battlefield
okay the community's been fighting
against that for a long time and we need
to get back I think to First principles
and we'll be just fine kind of hooker
you also a quick sort of follow-up which
is
they may not be 72 000 people in town
but but essentially at least sixty
thousand and most of them are civilians
right six thousand six thousand okay
yeah I mean is are there too many
civilians in uh so-called
well I don't I don't think I'm qualified
to answer that but I can tell you how
many there are there are
of that
6194 there are two thousand civilians so
maybe I don't know you tell me it's a
lot of civilians yeah I mean I'll just
jump in on I mean Richard you talked
about data um
I'd like to see the data because with as
many 18 x-rays that special forces that
come right in from the street as many of
them that come into the force I find it
hard to believe there's more NCO is
going to SF now than there were 10 or 20
years ago I just I don't see that that
is possible with the numbers perspective
if I could just interject a couple of
um data points and I apologize I didn't
bring these specific numbers but I can
tell you that we have collected data and
the significant majority of folks who go
through selection and do not make it
actually do have a track record of going
back to the regular forces and becoming
some of the longest serving and most
senior members of the NCO Corps so we do
have data that I think shows almost the
reverse that we become pillars
um sort of important pillars for the the
regular conventional Force for those who
don't end up making it not as many
actually leave entirely but they
actually stay in at a higher rate and
stay in for longer careers I'll also
point out that I think the better
comparison for the headquarters numbers
in Tampa is if you look at what it takes
for uh the Army Navy Air Force or
Marines the military service side
because that headquarters is both a
military service side and agcc
operational side there are two hats that
are worn by that Commander that is very
unique similar to the role that actually
secretary mayor ASD solick wears as a
operational policy advisor for the
secretary as well as a service sector
cherry-like role and so it is a little
bit complicated to unpack those
specifics um but I do think that
some of the questions that kernel hooker
that you raise are really good ones for
us to to reflect on because I think for
us to meet the challenge we set
ourselves and continue to be better we
have to question our underlying
assumptions and
I think it's always fair to say what
more can we do better and are we giving
the nation the return on investment and
I do believe that we are rebalancing the
force to be more effective in
competition spaces and to effectively
help pathfind for the Joint Force in
certain ways in this space and I think
that's an important role that we like to
play as Pathfinders
um but keeping that balanced with not
failing in our no fail missions
including those for CBO I think is
really important
um but I just wanted to sit there I'd
like I said it's not a debate but I did
want to set the record say that we do
have some data about the impact on the
conventional forces and that's actually
a little bit of counter-intuitive I
think
good morning everyone thank you for
being panelists today my name is
Michelle Poe I am in the Army under
Yusuf sock I've been in for 18 years and
I'm a member of the PRK cohort one class
that we've been taking this semester is
rethinking Special Operations and we've
been examining how Socom has 70 000
Personnel across the globe to conduct
Global operations and how certain
elements of it are are bloated and have
too many people
um and Carl hooker as you stated during
your brief basically once 9 11 kicked
off there was an ever expanding number
of elements being added to Special
Operations forces
um now that CT is winding down after 20
years and it may be time to start
cutting away those certain elements
um
one thing we've been talking about in
class is
is the government prepared to cut down
Special Operations
um to kind of direct it from the top
down and how in an environment where we
are not used to saying no or used to
essentially saying
I'm sorry about these 100 people have to
go back to the Army how do we do that is
there any ideas from the panelists
well well you might you might have
thought that as the G wat began to wind
down and that really wasn't something
that happened in 2020 that happened in
like 2014 or so
you might have expected that just as the
conventional Force began to decline in
size so too with the with the soft
community
in fact that has not been the case so
the the additions that were made at the
height of the G wat remain in place
today and year by year the
the the requests are actually more for
augmentation than for reduction
so I I would suggest that one of the
reasons that the socom staff is as large
as it is is not
to make it more rapid and agile and
responsive but to make it better able to
contend and compete in this competition
for resources inside the Beltway which
it does very very effectively
I mean it's it's true that Socom has
some service-like functions that's
undeniable
but the Army staff is tasked with
looking after when you include the
reserve component almost 10 times as
many people more than 10 times as many
people so the idea that both staff
should be the same size seems to me is
problematic I don't expect to see a
sharp reduction in the size of Special
Forces although I think it's I mean one
of your foundational strategic documents
you know makes the point over and over
and over again that quality is more
important than quantity
I think it's unarguable that if you get
twice as big you're not going to be able
to maintain the same level of quality as
you had before I just I just think
that's unarguable
and may contribute to some of the bad
things and disasters that we saw happen
over the last 10 or 15 years
I don't think you're going to get a lot
of senior people agreeing with with that
at least not publicly but but I think
it's something that's certainly true
and I don't expect a soft Community to
decline in size
I don't I mean I just don't think it's a
kind of issue that rises to the level of
the president's attention and I think it
would take presidential intervention for
something like that to happen
thanks everyone I'm Jackie deal from
long-term strategy a group in Washington
DC and I was wondering if you guys could
speak a little bit to how well we're
doing
um or how well either the The Joint
Force or the soft Community is doing at
understanding the PRC and the Chinese
Communist party as a competitor or as a
opponent
it took a while I think for us to get up
to speed on terror networks and the
radical islamist threat how would you
say we're doing on understanding
um our peer foe today
I'll take a jump at this and this is
from both me as the researcher and as an
old Intel guy
um
I think we're doing about as well as we
can
it's part of the research Chinese
military and educational
institutions published a lot
they publish a lot I publish a lot
unclassified
we have pretty good intelligence access
to a lot of the other Communications
at a lot of levels
it stops at the top tier of the CCP
though
so what is the pla or the pla Navy
likely to do in a certain situation I
think we have
a soft perspective and I think doing for
perspective a fairly good idea but
what's going to happen with G and his
six or seven closer ones we don't
um that's Dave's opinion I watch them
really closely trying to answer our
Commander's question how do we get G to
say not today to go to Taiwan
so there's a gap there isn't that cap
just maybe baked into the situation
which is she himself may not know what
he wants to do absolutely that's my own
and and
yes
as an old S2 in the army
a one-time armored Battalion Commander
asked me how come you can't tell me what
the enemy infamy in in in enemy infantry
battalions are going to do it in TC in
two days
I said
well here's your armor Battalion
Commander your buddy you live next door
to him what's he going to do in two days
he doesn't know so yes that is part of
it and also ESG is very powerful and
very well protected and has you know by
their law pretty much absolute control
I I feel we know more about it than we
did about the inner workings of Isis
when they started Rising I think we know
more about it than we did about the
inner workings of Al Qaeda
uh before 9 11 surely after 9 11.
because they write a lot
one final comment from Dancy Logan
because I I don't want to cut short with
that discussion on on PRC and our
understanding but I did want to say I
think the other thing that is important
to keep in mind uh
not only do again I think that I don't
think that we've grown too large and
soft as we've shifted and I think the
rules that we're gonna we are applying
and continue to play but part of that
comes down to a very basic fact which is
our most senior national leaders keep
turning this off
the key of asking soft to do the
missions so if the president keeps
asking us to do these missions
we are using our Force fully today they
are fully occupied there's nobody
sitting around just thinking great
thoughts except maybe the few of you in
this room
but but in general the vast majority of
our force is fully employed and they
keep being regularly employed
um for a spectrum of things that
arguably in some cases you could have
conventional forces doing but the senior
leadership of this country doesn't
appear willing to take that chance for
whatever reason and so I think that is
the fundamental factor that there are a
lot of people who've raised the
questions that chronologer has is have
we grown too large can we maintain the
quality the flip side of that is I think
using a lot of what we've learned over
the last 20 years we actually think that
our assessment and selection process
have gotten much better
and so in some ways our ability to
maintain quality has improved even as we
have grown and that is a little bit of a
counterbalance but there clearly is a
limit and I think that's where we ask
ourselves are we being used in the
missions that give the biggest return
again on investment for the nation
because while we are where we are and
arguably there are certain places we
would love to grow we actually can't
really grow very effectively I think
there is a real limitation there that
that you identify I don't think we hit
it today but I think we're very close
and so that actually becomes a
frustration as national leaders ask us
to do even more in certain spaces where
we haven't been able to grow
thanks to our well-informed and Lively
panel
foreign